لن نقبل باستبدال جندي من الكيان بجندي
اردني هكذا اعلنها الاردن بينما بلجيكا
تدعو مجددا الى فرض عقوبات على تلبيب
المانيا تورد اسلحه للكيان بعشره اضعاف
المعتاد مصر تقترب من النجاح بما فشلت به
دول العالم بعد احداث الشرق الاوسط عالم
الزلازل الهولندي ينذر بكارثه جديده
الحوثيون يسقطون طائره امريكيه في سماء
اليمن والامريكان يوضحون رغبتهم با ده
ترامب للسلطه طائره الاف 16 تقترب من
اوكرانيا وكيف تنفذ عمليه خاصه لتصفيه
مسؤول روسي المعارك لن
تتوقف هكذا هو حال الحروب تدخل اليها حتى
من ليس طرفا في معادله مع ريكيا ليعلق
رئيس وزراء الاردن بشر الخصاونه على
نقاشات الغرب حول سيناريوهات ما بعد الحرب
في القطاع مشددا على ان الاردن لن يرسل اي
قوات عسكريه للقطاع لن يقبل باستبدال
الجندي العبري بجندي اردني فيما كان
نتنياهو قد اعلن ان الجيش العبري يطوق
القطاع ويجري عمليات داخله مضيفا انه لن
يكون هناك وقف لاطلاق النار او توصيل
الوقود الى القطاع قبل ان تطلق الفصائل
سراح الرهائن الاسرائيليين مشددا لن نتوقف
هناك عقد وزراء خارجيه دول مجموعه السبع
اجتماعات مكثفه في طوكيو ليبدوا دعمهم
لهدو نت وممرات انسانيه بشكل عاجل في
القطاع دون الدعوه لوقف اطلاق النار لياتي
من مصر حل ازمه الهدنه التي عجزت عنها
بقيه الدول حيث صرحت مصادر مطلعه لوسائل
اعلام مصريه بان السلطات في مصر تقترب من
التوصل الى هدنه انسانيه في القطاع بحسب
قناه القاهره الاخباريه على ذات السياق
افادت صحيفه دي ستاندرد بان نائبه رئيس
الوزراء في بلجيكا بترا دي سوتر دعت الى
فرض عقوبات على تل ابيب بسبب تصرفاتها في
القطاع مضيفه انهم لا يمكنهم ان يقفوا
مكتوفي الايدي بينما يفقد الاطفال حياتهم
كل يوم وفي هذا الصدد دعت المسؤوله
البلجيكيه الى التعليق الفوري لاتفاقيه
الشراكه بين الاتحاد الاوروبي وتل ابيب
لكن في المانيا هناك راي اخر فقد افادت
وكاله دي بي اي بان المانيا اصدرت في عام
2023 تصاريح لتوريد اسلحه ومنتجات عسكريه
الى تل ابيب بقيمه حوالي 303 مليون يورو
وهو ما يزيد تقريبا 10 اضعاف عما كان عليه
عام
2022 ومع هذه الاحداث في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط عاد العالم الهولندي المثير للجدل
فرانك وجرب بيتس ليعلن على حسابه في منصه
اكس ان على العالم ان يجبر تل ابيب على
وقف هذا الجنون وبصرف النظر عن عدد
الضحايا فان هذا القصف سيكون له في نهايه
المطاف تاثير زلزالي كبير على المنطقه
وسيؤدي الى تسريع حدوث زلزال كبير على طول
البحر الميت في اليمن اعلنت القوات
المسلحه التابعه للحوثيين ان دفاعاتها
الجويه اسقطت طائره امريكيه ام كيو 9
اثناء قيامها باعمال عدائيه في اجواء
المياه اليمنيه ضمن الدعم العسكري
الامريكي للكيان واكد الحوثييون على حقهم
المشروع في الدفاع عن البلاد عن القضيه
المركزيه والتصدي لكل التهديدات المعاديه
ليصل تاثير حرب الشرق الاوسط الى الولايات
المتحده وعلى الرغم من بقاء عام على الان
خابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه فان استطلاعا
جديدا اجرته شبكه سي ان ان اكد مواصله
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب تقدمه على
الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن باربع نقاط مئويه
في مواجهه العوده الافتراضيه بين الاثنين
بصيص امل اوكراني الغايه الاوكرانيه تقترب
من التحقق فماذا لو تحققت هل نحن على موعد
مع تغير موازين القوه على الارض ولا اعلن
الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي وصول
الدفعه الاولى من طائرات اف 16 تبرعت بها
هولندا الى مركز تدريب في رومانيا قبل
تسليمها لكيف وتاتي هذه الخطوه تتويجا
لجهود اوكرانيا التي طالبت على مدى اشهر
تسليمها هذا النوع من الطائرات لمواجهه
التفوق الجوي الروسي على الارض ايضا اعلنت
كييف مسؤوليتها عن عمليه تصفيه سياسي
مدعوم من موسكو في منطقه لوغانسك التي
تسيطر عليها روسيا في شرق اوكرانيا وقالت
الاستخبارات العسكريه الا الاكرانيه في
بيان انها نفذت عمليه خاصه للقضاء على
ميخائيل فيليب بونينك الذي كان متورطا في
تنظيم غرف تعذيب لاسرى اوكرانيين فيما
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها
اسقطت خمس طائرات حربيه و1 مسيره اوكرانيه
جديده بينما خسر الجيش الاوكراني نحو
580 من جنوده خلال يوم